The "House of the Dragon" season finale was
pretty brutal, but it could have been terrifying.
The first season of the "Game of Thrones"
prequel includes several intense birth scenes
that emphasize the brutal nature
of childbirth in Westeros. Indeed,
the very first episode features a particularly
violent and bloody scene in which Queen
Aemma's labor goes horribly wrong — and
neither the mother nor the baby survives.
Episode 6 features two more birth scenes, one
in which Princess Rhaenyra Targaryen delivers
her baby and then immediately marches
through the Red Keep, trailing blood,
and another in which Laena Velaryon commits
suicide-by-dragon after her own labor goes awry.
"I've reached the limit of my art."
Yet the series saves its most disturbing birth
scene for the Season 1 finale, in which we see
Rhaenyra enter labor prematurely and deliver
a deformed, stillborn baby named Visenya.
Although the camera doesn't linger too
long on baby Visenya within the episode,
a recent Instagram post from
the series' prosthetic makeup
designer Barrie Gower gives us a
closer look at the baby's design.
Within the episode itself, it's hard to get a
good look at the stillborn Visenya as she is
covered in blood and held tightly in the arms of
Rhaenyra — but Gower's post illuminates some of
the finer details, with two brightly-lit images
of baby Visenya against a black background. The
first one highlights her deformed nose and sunken
face, and the second shows her cone-shaped skull.
The most striking deformity present in these two
images is the numerous dragon-like scales that
cover Visenya's head, chest, and back.
The second image shows that she has an
abundance of these scales on the back of her
head and running down her spine — and that the
back of her head features an almost horn-like
protrusion that accounts for her skull's shape.
Considering the immense amount of
detail shown in this small model,
it's surprising that these scales are
so obscured in the episode itself,
especially since they are specifically mentioned
in the series' source material, "Fire & Blood."
In the "Fire & Blood" chapter "The
Dying of the Dragons," a fool known
as Mushroom claims that Rhaenyra cursed
baby Visenya during her premature birth,
calling her a "monster" and yelling
for her to "get out." Mushroom goes
on to allege that these curses bore fruit
when the Visenya was finally born, saying,
"When the babe at last came forth,
she proved indeed a monster:
a stillborn girl, twisted and malformed,
with a hole in her chest where her heart
should have been, and a stubby, scaled tail."
It's worth mentioning that Mushroom's account of
the events in "Fire & Blood" is considered to be
unreliable and exaggerated. So it makes sense
that the design team chose to tone down his
version of Visenya for "House of the Dragon,"
while still making her somewhat dragon-like.
Although this silicone model does
not appear to include the tail,
it's clear that the prosthetics team paid
close attention to the details of Visenya's
malformed appearance and scales — culminating
in the design we see in Gower's Instagram post.
It's hard to grasp the immense attention
to detail that went into this model when
watching the episode itself due to Visenya's
incredibly brief appearance — though Gower's
post makes it abundantly it's clear that the
prosthetics department went above and beyond
to make this final birth scene really stand
out amongst all the others in the series.